es ist groß wie ein Schulbus und ein
echtes Monster im Gelände die Ukraine
hat diesen radschützenpanzer in Dienst
genommen geliefert von Kanada 39 Stück
insgesamt Bild Militärexperten ordnen
das Video als aktuell ein wo genau ist
in der Ukraine aufgenommen worden ist
unklar
das gigantische Fahrzeug dient dem
Transport von Truppen hatte Verteidigung
ein Maschinengewehr auf dem Dach
montiert
es ist 12 Tonnen schwer und eine
technische Meisterleistung viele Länder
haben diese Rollen der Militärbasis in
ihrem truppenfuhrpark
der gigantische Transporter kann auch
mit einem Geschützturm ausgestattet
werden durch seine spezielle Panzerung
an den Seiten und seine vier Achsen mit
beweglichen Reifen ist der in jedem
geländefahrtüchtig kommt fast überall
hin maximiert so die taktische Mobilität
der Operation
neben dem Fahrer der den Transporter
steuert per Lenkrad wie ein Bus passen
mit dem Kommandanten und acht Soldaten
insgesamt 10 Personen an Bord eine Norma
Größenvorteil der ist in Ukraine an
ermöglicht sicher in großer Stärke zu
einsetzen in einem Transportfahrzeug
auszurücken
auf bis zu 100 Sachen kann er
Schützenpanzer beschleunigen und ist
auch hier der russischen Konkurrenz
überlegen und so setzt die Ukraine jetzt
auf dieses kanadische Allround-Talent
auf dem Schlachtfeld